this video was made possible by news
voice a democratized news app created to
fight back against the filter bubbles
caused by corporate media download for
free from news voice calm slash Pakman
or click the link under this video
I've talked many times before about anti
intellectualism and pseudo-intellectual
ISM and pseudo-intellectuals
specifically but today I want to talk
about one specific component of this
pseudo-intellectual ism that's
particularly dangerous and it's what I
call pseudo intellectual pop nonfiction
ok if you're looking to find examples of
this pop nonfiction that makes people
think they know things you can actually
find a lot of it on the New York Times
bestseller nonfiction list and I want to
be clear I'm not criticizing reading or
people who read I'm not saying
everything on the New York Times
bestseller list is worthless far from it
in fact people should read they should
read way more many valuable books find
themselves on the New York Times
bestseller list but I'm talking about a
specific kind of nonfiction I was
perusing the list yesterday for example
and one book that fits this description
is the number-one book on that list
right now which is a book by Tucker
Carlson known as a ship of fools Fox
News anchor Tucker Carlson argues in the
book that America's ruling class is out
of touch with everyday citizens this is
the type of book that if you have the
capacity to read this there are way
better things you could be reading that
will actually make you more informed as
a consumer of news and a more informed
person in the world there is even an
example a few spots down on the list
right now it's a book by historian Doris
Kearns Goodwin it still sort of popped
but it's a valuable book it's about the
challenges that affected Lincoln the two
Roosevelts and LBJ you would be way
better off reading that then Tucker
Carlson's book but it's never going to
sell as well as Tucker Carlson's book
another example by Jeanine Pirro Fox
News judge Jeanine Pirro wrote a book
called Liars leakers and liberals it's
currently on the New York Times
nonfiction bestseller list people might
hear this and say David you're just
attacking right-wing books now stormy
Daniels has a book on the
right now I don't know if it's left or
right wing I mean she came to prominence
as an accuser of Trump that's also not a
book worth reading but I think it's more
obvious that that's not a book but worth
reading and people will realize that
that's not going to further your
intellectual development but sadly there
are people who read stuff like Tucker
Carlson right-wing radio guy Mark Levin
Fox News host Laura Ingraham has written
books Sean Spicer has a book out if you
can imagine it and the problem is that
people read those books and they think
that they're informed people who read
serious stuff merely because they're
reading nonfiction this is not serious
stuff and that's where I've developed
this idea that pseudo intellectualism
can be more dangerous than anti
intellectualism people who don't read
just don't read and you've got to deal
with them and try to reach them via the
platforms they pay attention to it might
be social media or TV or radio or
whatever people who read but read this
type of stuff believe that they are
truly more informed in an important way
than people who read other things and it
becomes much more difficult to reach
them because they think they are
informed by reading stuff like Laura
Ingraham and Tucker Carlson so there is
a huge difference between reading for
example homo Deus which is a relatively
pop science book by you've all know a
Harare which I just started reading then
Sean Spicer's book they're in the same
universe which is nonfiction that sells
really well but imagine if 50 million
Americans read homo Deus about the past
and future of humanity vs. Sean Spicer's
book or Tucker Carlson's book slamming
liberals we would be in a world so
different as to be totally or
recognizable in terms of our politics in
terms of who we elect to lead us in
terms of our understanding of the world
so some things I would encourage you to
check out number one the very short
introduction series is very good read
some of the basic topics history
philosophy economics game theory ethics
they are short 80 to 120 pages packed
with information look through the
references of those books the citations
and find other things to read I'm not
saying
you have to read academic books to be
informed probably only 15% of the
nonfiction i read would be considered
academic but I'm talking about serious
nonfiction for economics books look at
Angus Deaton book The Great Escape
that's a recent one that I've read how
to lie with statistics it's an old book
it's a short book but it is really
valuable information for being an
informed consumer of news Daniel
Kahneman's work which I've talked about
the sixth extinction by Elizabeth
Kolbert I'm just picking things I've
recently read we've got to get off of
this particular type of nonfiction and
the best analogy I can think of is that
it's white bread made with refined
bleached flour versus dark whole-wheat
bread with the seeds and all of the
stuff they're both bread right like
we're talking about books we're talking
about reading both people can be eating
bread both people are reading but what
you get from the good bread is a world
apart from what you get from the refined
bleached flour white bread are they both
better than nothing actually I don't
know I mean if you don't eat any bread
you might starve I actually would argue
that reading some of this nonfiction
nonsense could actually leave you less
informed than reading nothing at all but
a little bread can be a dangerous thing
or something I guess would be the
analogy send me your thoughts about this
particular type of nonfiction I'm on
twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show